it's everyone's biggest project there's
nobody that can really sit or sit around
the table and say well I got a story
topper for this one nobody it's probably
going to be fine probably going to be
successful every day on this
installation has been a struggle you
turn the corner and there's some new
challenge we just took a little chance I
think it is going to work but if it
didn't that'd be that I just keep
thinking of it like climbing a mountain
where I'm climbing in a certain point to
get to a place where I just have a
different perspective and the view is
different and I'm like wow we're up here
is what we're doing is it amazing but
right now I'm just kind of like no
grabbing on
we're gonna finish bolting this thing
together today we got the right tools we
need some more hardware some longer
bolts we're gonna move from the inside
out when we get the inside bolts
together we can move to the outside of
the Ring we are sending Morgan to get
the replacement bolts for the flanges
around the ring because we have to
replace these bolts with slightly longer
bolts and tighten them down with these
DTI washers it's especially important
that all the bolted connections be
really strong so we have these DTI
washers that's direct tension indicator
and those tell you when you've applied
enough torque to the special nuts and
bolts that we've selected for these
joints 500 pounds of torque and that's a
lot of forms we have to have the fridge
sticking out
they're all tightened down tight I can
flash the threads people who build art
don't necessarily have to deal with
these problems
48 down 48 more to go
he's never coming off
birthday boys coming down to see it
swing it's really nice to see it in the
air rather than just planned view an
elevation view where everything is kind
of flattened out it's kind of a
beautiful form we have some adjustments
to make on the pulleys they all will run
from this point around the pulley and
out the cables off a little bit then
it'll wear funny on the pulley this is
known as passenger 161
fine we're in the clear we're gonna
start feeding the wires in from the
outside into the center thimble which is
what controls the whole piece and just
be a spoke of wires 445 cables going in
and then at that point we start to move
up with that and work underneath it with
a cable net we're gonna have a bunch of
these tags on them hanging off the ring
we don't want like coils of cable
hanging loose so we want to contain this
cable as much as we can always watch
when we're pulling these things straight
that we don't have any kinks that we're
gonna pull into it because that'll
create a point of fatigue on the wire if
we kink anything you got a we got to
remake it just did some quick - we're
gonna be very very very slow and careful
whenever these cables come in contact
with the deck we broke a cable today
took us about an hour to repair and
remake that wire and get it replaced
bringing the ring down and I felt bad
take a break so what are we on schedule
no who really can know we have the
completion of the control cables running
through the pulleys on the ring to the
thimble the cable it wants to to say and
the only way to avoid that is to put it
under a lot of tension this is the 10th
- Tron 3000 that measures census
strength of cable the other thing those
triangles do is they hold down the
cables of the cable net they hold them
together
so that the cable net can't to form too
far fortunately the cable ferry let me
know
these are the much anticipated lower
pulleys right now we're just gonna
finger tighten the nuts on there so that
when we put the weights on the whole
thing can pull apart as much as its
going to and then we'll tighten
we have 500 pounds of sand that we're
putting on right now which represents
the amount the artwork pushes down on
the truss
I hold on second is cooling off it's
actually remarkably flat
they look cool runs in the air here nice
paper finish or the weave dance yeah I
can see that top the top cord of the
dress and the whole thing just lines up
it's perfect
our goal is to get into this weave today
this mess
so here between we all thing without
I really hope and Ruben as well because
it wasn't entirely well yesterday and I
feel like it made me a little bit of a
fall we need Ruben on this one more than
ever I slept in this morning we're gonna
build Rubens little weave pavilion the
weave Zeebo we're building a platform
a scaled-down version of the ring will
come in we're gonna bring all the cables
through through the model and start
having them walk out to their final
destination taking the cables down
getting them to the right places
they all have to cross one other in this
special order and if that order is wrong
the cables will rub on one other and
that could potentially lead them to
break you got to know where this goes it
goes on the outside 246 391 12 we skip
that here we need to do later 362 twist
that not wire
over 72 guess again guess
this is too
when I looked at all the wires coiled up
this morning and I just thought oh my
god what have we done
pull it through this little mask
this one is the short you may have a
problem I can't tell if this right oh my
god what have I gotten myself into it
was a big gamble complete disaster I was
like oh my gosh six months of work and
this is what it's come down to
we're gonna get strung up and rode out
of town
you